the latest episode of the walking dead
diverged picks up shortly after
long-term survivors
carol and daryl have had a heartbreaking
falling out as they saunter back toward
alexandria it's clear that things
between them are still very frosty
and they come to a literal fork in the
road in the fifth episode of the walking
dead's
season 10c carol's search for a problem
to solve
begins with her picking up a tattered
scarf off the streets of alexandria
when she finds jerry working in one of
the fields he eyes the dirty fabric
carol explains that she wants to wash it
and mend the holes
somebody loved it and i just want to fix
something although jerry seems a little
concerned
he also doesn't have any other task for
carol to take on
she creates one for herself by
announcing that she'll contribute to the
rebuilding efforts
by making a pot of soup for everyone
however that seemingly simple assignment
doesn't go as planned some of the
problems carol encounters while making
the soup stem from the hardships of
post-apocalyptic life
however others are the result of her
anxious desire to fix
things pulling her attention in
different directions she starts and
stops the project
many times taking detours to collect
more greens
make an improvised rat trap to try and
catch a rodent that's invaded her home
and fix a solar panel so that she can
get her trusty crock pot working again
by the time night falls none of the
issues have been resolved
the rat is still loose the soup is still
just ingredients
and the scarf is still a tattered rag in
her hairy desire to fix something
carol ends up not accomplishing anything
other than
driving herself into a dark mood while
carol struggles with her soup
daryl is having a difficult time
completing his own scavenging mission
his quest to repair the motorbike takes
the better part of the day
and sees him having several close calls
with walkers
in the end he's able to get the bike
working again and even finds
some useful supplies but it's clear that
his falling out with carol both
figuratively and literally
set him back the irony of diverged is
that carol and daryl spin the episode
apart
looking for a solution to a problem that
the other could easily solve
if daryl hadn't pushed carol away he'd
have the tool he needs to fix his bike
and if carol hadn't left she'd have
something she could easily fix
had they not started the episode by
going down diverging paths in the woods
everything would have been much simpler
for both of them however as anyone who
has ever had a falling out with a good
friend knows
sometimes there's no easy fix for a
problem like this
while daryl remains stoic carol gives
viewers some more direct insight into
how she's feeling
confiding in dog while the two were
cuddling in bed
come back he always comes back
although she expresses hope for daryl's
return she is much more pessimistic in
her assessment of herself
wondering if everyone would be better
off if she just got out of their hair
during the night dog wakes carol up
because he can hear the rats scurrying
around somewhere behind the walls
unable to let the problem go unsolved
carol furiously rips apart the drywall
leaving behind a massive physical
manifestation of her woes
jerry picks up on this the next day when
he stops by to pay carol a visit
although the soup is finally bubbling
away in the crock pot
she's clearly still carrying around a
lot of pain jerry offers to tell her one
of ezekiel's sayings to give her some
perspective
but carol isn't interested maybe i don't
need a saying
maybe i just need to fix what i broke in
find me
daryl blamed carol for the disappearance
of his close friend connie
who was lost in a cave collapse that as
he sees it
was caused by carol recklessly seeking
revenge on whisperer leader alpha
although carol believes that her actions
were in service of a greater good
she still understands that they came
with negative consequences and the guilt
of it weighs heavily on her
it's not the first time we've seen her
struggle in this regard but
daryl being the one to pin the blame on
her seems to be a twist of the knife
that may be
too much for her to bear jerry has
already intuited that her pain has
something to do with daryl
friend is someone who thinks you're
perfect even if everyone else thinks
you're broken
carol isn't buying it though what if you
really are broken
[Music]
what if your best friend just realized
it a whole lot later than everyone else
did
after her conversation with jerry carol
apologizes to the tattered scarf before
abandoning her plans to repair it
and throwing it in the garbage she walks
outside and sees daryl getting home from
his scavenging trip
the two have a stilted conversation and
when carol tries to give the swiss army
knife back
daryl tells her to keep it the episode
ends with them each going into their
separate homes
no closer to reaching any kind of
solution it's clear that this rough
patch in their relationship
is painful for both carol and daryl but
that neither is quite sure how to
navigate it
the characters have known each other for
a long time and have been through a lot
together but long-term relationships of
any kind are difficult they have their
ups and downs and sometimes they
unfortunately break apart
it's possible that this low point for
carol and daryl will pass
and we'll see them buddied up again
presumably just in time for the daryl
carroll spin-off series
for now though it looks like there's
sorrow for the people they've lost
and the guilt of their decisions are
going to keep them at arm's length from
one another
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one